hi this is Mario with Mario's math
tutoring coming to with another math
video to help you boost your score in
your math class improve your
understanding and hopefully make math a
lot less stressful so in this video
we're going to talk about is how to work
with spheres finding surface area and
volume so spheres are real simple
compared to some of the other shapes
because there's really only one
dimension and that's the radius
sometimes they'll give you the diameter
but you can just cut it in half and
that'll be the radius so if you were to
go any direction from that center point
to the outer edge of the the ball of the
sphere that's the radius so it just has
that one dimension so our two formulas
we're going to work with here our
surface area which is 4 PI R squared and
volume which is 4/3 PI R cubed now just
a hint for keeping them straight our
cubed cubed think three-dimensional 3d
squared think like you're covering the
area of the sphere with little squares
ok so a two-dimensional ok so that's one
way you can kind of remember which one
goes with which so let's find the
surface area the outer surface so we're
gonna do is we're gonna use the 4 pi
radius squared now the radius is just
going to be half the diameter so they're
giving us diameters 20 so that's gonna
be 10 so 10 squared is a hundred times 4
is 400 so that's 400 PI units squared
whatever the units are K inches
centimeters meters you can leave Pi in
here or if you want you can put 3.14 and
then just route it to the nearest tenths
or hundredths place but I'm just gonna
leave it at any exact OK form now the
volume we're gonna use 4/3 PI R cubed
now the radius is 10 so that's going to
be 4/3 pi times 10 cubed 10 cubed is a
thousand ok anything divided by 1 is
itself so a thousand times 4 is 4,000 pi
divided by 3 times 1 times 1 which is 3
so that gives us units cubed and that's
the volume of the sphere so I hope
you're finding these videos helpful go
ahead and subscribe to the channel check
out some of my past videos and I've got
some more videos like this coming for
you so stay tuned I'll see you in the
next video